but welcome to this broadcast our Monday
evening live show seems on one I've got
the mic on looks good Cheddar's active
excellent so let's get going and play
some five minutes games what is for
reading - 428 it's not bad
could be worse I will gas is on here and
he's got to 603 not to gain sign it when
I get Bruce low there was a request I
should play some of my future before
repertoire I can do that here we go I
guess it's work in progress so if I'm
failing here with the French that that
would be bad good anyway not a big deal
what is Boris Allah we doing 97 or 96 s
on here let's go the 53 and here we will
get an IQ p position that is a strange
move Queen b3 and think I'm I should win
a pawn down so I can just take 7 now ok
can you even grab d-file huh
is there a big issue with taking d5 now
don't see it let's do it
okay I take takes this one okay that
make sense yeah I should have paid more
attention to this move and not good yeah
not good
okay look b8 is probably on its agenda
that's true Bishop a4 yeah sorry
much much is asking in the chat about
the missing daily videos yeah I'm not
doing the daily videos anymore at the
moment at least I'm currently not
feeling much like playing playing blitz
all the time I think it's just a matter
of yeah it might be different at some
other some other time
but currently I'm not really much into
playing blitz as I was before I just
done it comes and goes
check
in particular I don't like so much to do
it daily there are just days where I'm
too busy and it is just a complete it's
just a bit of a hassle to do it daily
okay so what's going on here I'm still a
pawn up ninety six surprise maybe maybe
here taking the pawn pawn the night will
come to f5 or d5 to skip this form job
how to make some sort of progress in
this pollution it's not that easy has
got a fairly good located so can I trade
Queens I'm not sure that this would help
just be a past year the idea is looking
for I know that I felt helps me and
weakens his position quite a bit the
chick however I don't know let's just go
back
image three is slightly and each was
slightly annoying I would like to get
rid of the Queen we're not so happy
about this move
Simon Williams lost in f-m today in the
British Championships and well that's
not very surprising is it yeah with this
with this extremely sharp style he
should lose many games I mean he also
wins many games but just it just comes
with the with the risk involved okay so
I'm getting a little bit more
coordination here each four is a ticked
and ya can also check here and that
doesn't do all that much say anything
else I can check here only six but not
quite sure what that does okay I'm
taking this
it is Boris slotnick by the way thank
you sir Ukrainian or Russian I'm not
quite sure I know it that's a
substantial difference I am but I don't
know time more name exactly not good
not very nice here this pollution
I really miss played that really nice
pollution now it's got the strong knight
on d5 against this not so good Bishop no
both
you
didn't see why I shouldn't take it we
have just know I couldn't have taken
my position is okay now I think it's
just roughly equal he's got 20 I've got
a bit of a time problem
[Music]
16 seconds unfortunately
14 seconds
check speaking quite at home
check-check Gras offered check
fortunately I cannot win anymore because
of my lack of material gain drawn
playing one time and you're so slow it's
really really great stuff anyway um so
um I had to finish this game now I can
watch the channel with more and I'm
going to request a new game of course
yeah I mean I'm still doing videos for
my channel just not in that very
straightforward I have got something on
today tomorrow this show and so on I
just don't want to do it daily anymore
I've got really gotten to I had many
situations where I was basically sitting
there and I had to do videos because
there wasn't on the next day it wasn't
anything planned for the day can't sign
if you really don't feel like doing it
the result is not great so what do we do
this guy has beaten me twice I'm not
going to play the Budapest can really
have to disappoint you there I don't
like to play this opening so I'm going
to try the my old tried and trusted
boggle
meat-grinder asks if I ever consider
considered to do on a Kings Indian
attack repertoire for white actually not
that's not a terrible idea
um King Xenia Tech is very decent a cute
thing video oh that's interesting I
haven't done that for ages that's true I
could do that I have to keep that in
mind
hmm
okay just plug into three here yeah one
thing that I'm really not sure about I
have to check how this works
bloom I'm going to be on holiday in some
weeks and I might be able to do some
videos from from a holiday spot depends
on the quality of the Wi-Fi which is
kind of kind of random yeah I've been to
that place or from and it is usually
quite okay it's got a friggin fly in my
office driving me crazy so my opponent
is trading stuff and I really don't like
this position some our continent to
really stay on vocal position
not really entertaining
and the tires is quite reasonable but it
you have to play it correctly and this
is not really how it should look like it
also bid weird that I have a zero score
against someone with such a bad reading
relatively bad reading but you know yeah
there is no increment pool on the ICC
still no no change
the main problem with the budapest
gambit is that the pawn structure that
you usually get it's just not great I
mean you usually get this pawn structure
with the DND porn traded and this is
just better for white I don't like it
I'm just I prefer white a lot in those
Budapest a pawn structures where the DNA
porn are traded white just has
controller with d5 it is just not not
very nice so I want the b-pawn somehow
so I should not be worse anymore even
though it's still not still not big fun
to play this how to do it Jim Bishop d7
Bishop to c6 something like that you
might win de Paul we need to see the
Latvian gambit more often it's totally
underrated I really don't know people
have some sort of obsession with this
opening and I don't understand why I
just uh Turk rap I mean I've looked at
it again actually because of the serious
or this efore repertoire that I'm
working on and I mean the only problem
providers to choose one of the great
lines because there are so many that are
bad okay so I can check check and then
lie to g7 probably no I should actually
win the bishop that's better
alright this is actually fairly safe
King position so what quite sure you
cannot really do all that much to sleep
Tommy Queen here seems to be the idea
Quincy to marry so check check check
check
quite resigned okay yeah I think in the
UH King rapper to I actually have a
different vegetation I would have to I
think I have a different reputation but
but everything is just good yeah almost
everything what about what a Gus you see
how he is on it he is playing maybe is
playing a three minute
hmm it's curious he's not there I know
he has left sir that's bad
when illegals came with the fun okay I
have a game requests out of course but
not yet on it's funny by the way
last week on Monday was the last day
that I do smell all the mouse it broke
down on me logitech g502 and then I have
gotten a new mouse which it was a
cheaper one also from Logitech wireless
one they totally didn't work so what did
I do
not Saturday game design it went to the
store and bought the same Logitech mouse
again
okay so again efore against the lazy
penguin okay the lazy penguin what am I
doing here only one yeah I think that's
right yeah now like usually takes yeah
this is a line where black is just a
smidgen worse not much but just a tiny
bit worse why it is just a bit quicker
in taking the center think I could
deform it's not much but it is nice
okay so before let's take it and how
long did it take me from 2000 to 2002
hundred I assume you're meaning you're
about classical time control chess I
have to think about that actually let me
think about it yeah roughly two to three
years I think and so let's see um what
to do what to do what to do I was
thinking Queen a forward
it doesn't help all that much
you
Susan
not sure where I should put the Queen
and drug think I do the see I mean I
don't know maybe Quincy one is coming
and I playbook see one and possibly the
queen bag the Kings gambit is bad for
white yeah I don't know okay I have no
really clear pinion on that I think it's
it is not great but I'm not sure if it's
really worse for white if you play
perfectly I think in maybe it's it's
equal also what am I doing here actually
it's just good for me
alright I've got the two bishops in the
normal one this is a nice position now
c5 maybe hangs now it's comfortable it's
really comfortable it's very tough to be
worse in such a position with white
you've got the center and you've got got
the bishop pair so he gives me the c5
pawn so
and it could be a little bit of material
on the border
uh-huh where do you go if I take this
and then will be fired for example or
just will be five immediately where is
this going to see for me
let's just keep the tension I don't know
if this is good I don't know about that
one
I even the immediately v was good hey
hey the penguin is 105 years old most
give him some credit
yeah maybe he is that old
I didn't see this beforehand but this is
strong bishop takes all night takes
bishop takes could even work in which it
takes 92 rupee six nights you form this
is probably easier easier to play
yeah maybe he's a born on December 19th
this is possible of course I don't want
to give him you form time morning
I'm a little bit down on time but
position is very good of course just
need to keep control my King is totally
safe that's actually not helping if I do
that what is actually helpful at the end
I've got cattle aged six you should be
for coming
check-check
this will not hold absolutely not
bling black resigned
okay that's also good our game that was
nice
good controlled game yeah this is served
pretty comfortable line for why this
this whole thing where they take on your
three it is sound for black kids solid
but it's very very controlled for white
okay I've got any game requests out yeah
thanks for the good feedback on my name
is Owen Babu books DN Starnet is posting
in the channel I have some projects
always in the making but it's not take a
what a paper book this is just not it
doesn't make any sense economically food
whatever mind with this book is it's a
complete complete joke compared to what
you can run with other ways of
publishing because farmers writing my
great successes is they really doing the
headsman detected that's sounds funny
okay I wonder if if I take and play
Queen d7 and I think this is actually
interesting
check this ending is interesting with in
five and six I've got some good porn
leaders okay we don't get the ending
he takes it just like in the bayonet
right it really looks like he knows what
he's doing
yeah he won't think for in a second year
because it's probably so rubbish in what
I'm doing
not even a single second is needed
okay so Queen f5 light p5 is really
really awful
there is big issue and if five is coming
really quickly and at the NC 7 is
falling
I don't have the main tournament opening
with us one in four these days I I just
play basically everything okay I can
take on d5 in this position
it really does not look good does not
look good
you
so I'm a pawn up for the moment check
okay I was thinking it would take with
you look
[Music]
look to the 647
Oh Simon a tough tough tough
yeah I'm okay now but the time is not
great check
[Music]
41 seconds then can get rid of the night
maybe coming to see - and it's okay
and the book is good you first think
later I'm just like I had to play this
game there was a question about really
Hendrix book I like it so that's a cool
look
learned at the pawn unfortunately
check-check
I'd like to get the night onto f3
it would give some practical chances at
least I also has no idea how to win it
and my time the targets the Molina show
the position is bad would doesn't look
like he's got anything great and store
him
and I will try to win on time
here's okay I mean he's got he's got the
porn and everything so he can check
exactly then you're playing check check
look h4 mate so annoying check put no
time and his chat with lucky for taking
time ah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah I lost
so much time at the beginning and I
couldn't really catch up the position
was even I think okay from him I know
somewhere around here he's got nothing
but the time he just played everything
here instantly and had pressure which is
a huge thing
okay so game started the filter check so
the filter check that looks like yeah
this is the line after bedroom I have
forgotten about that that's extremely
boring but black is okay I don't know
this one
and when I testified logic isn't really
great yeah I maybe have to go to a3
looks a little bit like it it's not
ideal he might have some ecigs bestows
or stuff on the long diagonal I was a
bad boy I have to waiter with the for
Castle first or something
it's not nice here
if you take it I guess yeah but this is
how bad is that the chicken is the thing
and really is an opening and opening
problem
cat that sucks
that really sucks okay
can I take on these five or is that I
kind of have to so that at least I have
a part for my bit for my trouble so
teeny to still check Bishop II one and
now the ape on a four a five a six run
Forrest run
okay that's a cool news but what about
the book can I kick it around with 94 or
maybe h4 get this activated q1
okay
it looks extremely wiki ah but I can't
take c2 here right
take take look-see one that isn't all
that clear
it isn't so clear
if I get if I can keep the two pawns it
just just a simple ad and I can keep the
two pawns my position is good if I
cannot
my position is bad it's just he just
that simple I'm trying to trade here I
need to activate of course my h1 work
okay so I think I'll take and now King
King here and then I can take out I give
up the gap on I need I need this book g1
i th I don't care I don't care
ones have to lie I will see one I
couldn't play unfortunately would it be
nice if I could have gotten that in but
didn't work
some would appear to a measure really
what does this I mean maybe it's just
bad but I am NOT certain the cell not
sure what he's taking away the c5 post
for his bishop this is something that
I'm not not really fearing check
look a six coming and then who
interesting okay so I have to take it
don't think I can allow I can the lower
Wow whoa
check interesting very very tough if I
first maybe check check time warning
black resigns Jeff there was a really
tough game but the passers in the books
usually they are stronger but I don't
know it might have been a lost em it was
very much depending on specific tactics
as well okay new game request gets one
watch more in
okay so what about my score today
I scored okay with white yeah with the
e4 stuff but black I'm suffering yeah
I've got the week rest out
yeah I hope and pretty much believe
you're all looking forward to the next
the next events that we have the seen
field Cup coming up gain the Larned
looking forward to the rapid and blitz
which has Kasparov what the heck with
just aspirin playing really caught the
Latvian okay
I think this is what I have in my
upcoming repertoire is another
recitation scene field camp is starting
tomorrow or the day after tomorrow if
I'm not totally wrong
so h3 mmm can also think about 95 but it
it's probably not doing that much
not sure not sure what's best here we do
this I don't know it's a little bit
overwhelming with this development
advantage yeah I kind of expected him to
do that it's the only way to justify
this
soon
I might lose the game while I shouldn't
I have it it just it's just an
unimportant Blitz game and opening is
still complete crap with it so let's see
yeah it's not it's right I didn't play
it right I didn't play it right quite
clearly yeah
do it just tt6 I guess I do
I didn't do it right that's pretty clear
it's still still I don't see anything
great for from Black Knight f5 is a
pretty pretty big idea now that I was
made that I managed to move the King ya
Knight f5 is a threat I wonder what to
point us ok takes it yeah so taking
taking isn't that great I think I will
keep this all nice you for maybe
and still sucks this position for black
mainly Bishop h6 was better I don't know
but this I have to catch up on the clock
a little bit
timewise it's not great it looks
entirely totally crazy
and maybe actually takes takes 94 added
this kind of crap could work m-maybe I
have to tick with the rook actually yeah
[Music]
now maybe SM tick tockia night h5 some
garbage like that could work Queen fired
probably he caught up on the clock I'm
still threatening work to f1
time-wise
this is falling behind now that's good
taking deform and the queen is still
attacked maybe he can somehow get some
small pieces for for the Queen or some
queer Queen b6 something like that this
though cuz us f2 it takes deform and h5
still hangs check let's check black
resign and I didn't do this wider I mean
this is an opening that shouldn't reach
move to any aid how do you actually I
think I'm okay up to here I couldn't
quite figure out what to do now I
thought that this isn't all that
terrible it's good for Wyatt a bit it's
not like black is falling apart and I
think you should what was what did I do
wrong now okay let's not analyze let's
not analyze just claim
yeah game game requests out
well I pretty much kept my rating maybe
gain some points at least I'm pretty
sure Lee staying above 2400 yeah not
that many people counted on in the 5
minute pool game started
I'll check evident to the person 1
against me earlier playing super quickly
in that way so I'm going to go for an
entirely different line this is one of
those dances it's not really great but I
forgot why
a five I don't know
now this is this is leading to
complications and chicks night you okay
I'm going to try that and 93 is
interesting in this pollution
it pretty much has to take unless there
is something really good there and I
don't think there is I can't I take C to
them and if he has to give me the dark
squared Bishop that would be pretty nice
yeah hey there hey Alec I lied ahead if
not would all be successful and I've
moved it a lot yeah 9 F 6 and this guy
now playing magic playing magic Musa or
what so I can take all the stuff you
will take a 8 or what what's going on
G let me do this first if I take d6 now
it will not be enough
so if a cheek stick the Queen takes the
walk
hmm I'm an exchange down in this
position but I have nine to 86
that's a really really tough position
[Music]
take CSD six so have to take with this
okay so wookie 893 comes with a temple
and Bishop d7 till they win the night
I'm okay but I'm not really sure if I do
that I manage that
electron night jumps okay I was thinking
to be too actually if it doesn't have a
square then and let's put it on to your
phone
weenie four is a good square you might
have be 595 but all my pieces are
brilliant then I can always get a pole
at the end of this
isn't Bishop d7 he's got b5
this could be five
this isn't this isn't super clear think
maybe it is let's film I'm still not
sure
look the face meeting
time warning yes
Seaforth hanging 92 is an idea I'm
really not totally sure about this
maybe he's got something with
where are you going now with this rogue
knight GF to check the alaka'i Knights
can be tricky
it's another fork on f2 quite resigned
Hey it was probably losing 4 black
somehow but I don't know I didn't think
it was already eating yes I was hunky
did I have something this is really
intriguing engine gives black gives
black an advantage here slight advantage
even here it gives equal effect funny
so it wasn't super clear stop risk is
equal here funnier anyway there was a
cool game for the end of the session I
hope you enjoyed it I'll definitely will
be back next week and you know we have
to look a little bit with with the other
shows the sinful cop is on and so on
very likely I would love to show next
week Monday at the same time but we'll
we'll see what happens thanks a lot for
watching
I'll definitely we'll be back soon
bye bye
you